[Música]
tras romper alianzas con los partidos
tradicionales el presidente de Colombia
Gustavo Petro reforma su gabinete
ministerial con el objetivo de superar
las divisiones que bloqueaban las
principales promesas de su
administración entre los titulares
renovados salud Hacienda e interior
[Música]
por primera vez desde que empezó la
invasión rusa vuelo
mantienen una conversación telefónica el
presidente chino anunció que enviará un
grupo de representantes a Ucrania para
mediar en el conflicto en el campo de
batalla el grupo Wagner reclama más
munición a Moscú
el ejército regular de Sudán declara
estar dispuesto a extender La tregua con
los paramilitares mientras los civiles
permanecen atrapados en medio de una
crisis humanitaria ya van más de 500
muertos según el Ministerio de salud
sudanés
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
masdeú y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles abrimos esta edición
informativa de nuevo en Colombia porque
el presidente Gustavo Petro anunció la
recomposición de su gabinete por el
momento el mandatario cambiará a los
titulares de Hacienda agricultura
interior ciencia tic transporte y al
director del departamento administrativo
de la presidencia destaca la salida de
la ministra de salud Carolina corcho
pues ella lideraba la polémica reforma a
la salud en medio de la cual ocurre esta
sacudida recordemos que ayer martes a
Petro pidió la renuncia de todos sus
ministros y anunció el fin de la
coalición que formaba su plataforma el
pacto histórico con partidos
tradicionales y la alianza verde una
ruptura de alianzas motivada por los
desacuerdos en torno a Pilares
fundamentales del cambio que prometió el
presidente
como la mencionada reforma de la salud
nuestro compromiso es siempre Buscar las
mejores condiciones de vida para todos
los ciudadanos hoy se construye un nuevo
gabinete que ayudará a consolidar el
programa de gobierno programa que será
la base de un acuerdo nacional Franco y
sincero Para seguir trabajando al
servicio de las comunidades de todo el
país en otras noticias de América Latina
la presidenta de Perú Dina boluarte
decretó el estado de emergencia en todas
las fronteras del país es decir en los
departamentos que limitan con Ecuador
Colombia Brasil y chile la mandataria
justificó la medida con el objetivo de
incrementar el control de ciudadanos
extranjeros las zonas limítrofes se
suman así a la región de puno donde ya
rige el régimen de excepción que fue
declarado para reprimir las protestas a
desatadas por la destitución y la
detención de Pedro Castillo quien
recordemos se encuentra en prisión
provisional acusado de Rebelión
en Estados Unidos Walt Disney World
demandó al gobernador de Florida a ron
de santis Disney acusa al mandatario
republicano de llevar a cabo una campaña
de castigo y represalias que amenazan el
futuro económico del grupo y viola sus
derechos constitucionales pero la
disputa entre Disney y el gobierno de
Florida viene de lejos el estado quiere
suprimir el autogobierno del que goza
Disney en sus parques de Orlando se
trata de una respuesta de los
republicanos a la oposición pública de
la empresa de entretenimiento contra la
ley que prohíbe hablar de identidad de
género en las escuelas de Florida
y Mientras tanto en Brasil el
expresidente brasileño Jair bolsonaro
declaró ante la Policía Federal en el
marco de la investigación sobre la toma
de Brasilia del pasado 8 de enero que
recordemos tuvo lugar pocos días después
de la toma de Posesión del gobierno de
Luis Ignacio lulada Silva el líder
investigado acudió en compañía de sus
abogados y no hizo comentarios a la
prensa la causa está en manos del
tribunal supremo y pretende identificar
a los promotores del intento de golpe de
estado y a quienes financiaron la
movilización de los miles de militantes
de ultraderecha que asaltaron las sedes
de la presidencia del Congreso Nacional
y de la Corte Suprema
y Cuba continúa inmersa en una crisis
por la falta de gasolina mientras el
gobierno de Miguel díaz-canel atribuye
el problema a los proveedores
internacionales crece la molestia entre
los cubanos que no solo viven la falta
de productos básicos sino también el
encarecimiento del costo de vida y como
consecuencia de esta situación fueron
canceladas las emblemáticas
celebraciones del primero de mayo Rafael
Pérez nos cuenta más
persiste la crisis de combustible en
Cuba las extensas filas de automóviles
en las cercanías de las estaciones de
gasolina son el indicador de la falta
del carburante según las autoridades por
el momento la situación permanecerá
igual o sea han mantenido reducido las
cifras que hoy podemos distribuir Para
qué para no tener una un
desabastecimiento total de combustible
en el país Venezuela histórico
abastecedor de crudo a la isla ha bajado
considerablemente los envíos a Cuba un
vacío que la Habana ha intentado suplir
con envíos de Rusia y México sin embargo
esa vía tampoco ofrece pronta solución
ellos han tenido problemas también con
los insumos para producir y han tenido
problemas para poder cumplir con con
nosotros los los compromisos En medio de
una inflación sin precedentes la falta
del diesel genera un alza adicional de
los precios uno un taxi Ah cuesta
doble o el triple de lo que costaba
anteriormente Y cuando uno le pregunta
dice es que es combustible es que no hay
gasolina es que Y entonces es muy
difícil es muy difícil también que hay
pocos hay pocos carros también pero un
anuncio en particular marcó la gravedad
de la escasez la dirección del país
suspendió las acostumbradas marchas por
el día de los trabajadores y se decidió
por una celebración más austera
manteniendo su conmemoración pero en
condiciones de racionalidad y máxima
autoridad este trance se desarrolla
pocos días de que el gobierno cubano
encabezado por Miguel Díaz canel tomara
posesión en un segundo mandato la falta
de un plan económico efectivo por parte
del gobierno la crisis económica mundial
así como las sanciones impuestas por
Estados Unidos han hecho que la isla
experimente una de las crisis económicas
más fuertes de su historia reciente
vamos ahora con información relativa a
Ucrania porque por primera vez desde que
empezó la invasión rusa voladimir
selenskymping mantuvieron una
comunicación directa según medios
estatales de China a través de una
llamada telefónica el presidente chino
informó a su homólogo ucraniano que
enviará una delegación a Ucrania para
mediar en una salida negociada al
conflicto con Rusia el jefe de la
diplomacia de la Unión Europea calificó
la llamada de muy buena noticia y por
otro lado en el campo de batalla el
líder del grupo Wagner reclamó más
munición al kremlin ante lo que
describió como la Inevitable
contraofensiva ucraniana Ramiro cuevar
berena nos amplía
un sorpresivo acercamiento entre China y
Ucrania el presidente chino dialogó
telefónicamente con su homólogo
ucraniano voladimir zelenski el primer
contacto entre naciones desde el
comienzo de la invasión de Rusia tras la
comunicación el país asiático anunció
que un envío especial viajará
Próximamente aquí china enviará un
representante especial del gobierno
chino para asuntos euroasiáticos a
Ucrania y otros países y sostendrá
conversaciones con todas las partes para
resolver la crisis de Ucrania allí
nominó un nuevo embajador en suelo chino
tras el llamado el cual fue bien acogido
por la comunidad internacional desde
Rusia hasta Estados Unidos
he mantenido una larga y significativa
conversación con el presidente pin creo
que esta llamada así como el
nombramiento del embajador de Ucrania en
China darán un fuerte impulso al
desarrollo de nuestras relaciones
bilaterales
estos acercamientos de Beijing un
estratégico Aliado de Rusia se da ante
el inminente avance de la contraofensiva
ucraniana de primavera algo esperado
para las próximas semanas y que preocupa
las tropas del grupo Wagner el ejército
ucraniano está totalmente listo para
salir y cortar nuestros flancos nadie ha
cubierto nunca nuestros flancos todas
esas historias sobre impedir que las
reservas entraran en bacmut son pura
basura el ejército ruso no ha disparado
ni un solo tiro nadie les está dando
munición y a ellos ni a nosotros se dio
una orden criminal de no entregar
munición
se estima que se recrudezcan los
combates en la región de saporilla y en
la ciudad de bakmuth el principal
escenario de enfrentamientos en los
últimos 14 meses y que tiene el 80%
controlado por Rusia según el grupo
Wagner
y mientras avanzan los combates sobre el
terreno también hay espacio para una
cierta negociación en el marco de un
nuevo acuerdo de intercambio de
prisioneros el Ministerio de defensa de
Rusia informó que Ucrania liberó a 40
militares rusos a cambio de 44
ucranianos según la cifra anunciada por
las autoridades de kiev El kremlin
aseguró que los militares rusos que se
encontraban en cautiverio en Ucrania
serán trasladados a Moscú en avión
y actualizamos ahora la situación en
Sudán porque este miércoles el líder del
ejército regular abdel fatal alburán
declaró estar dispuesto a alargar La
tregua vigente acordada el lunes con los
paramilitares un alto del fuego que ha
tenido más éxito que los anteriores Y
que ha permitido la evacuación de
ciudadanos extranjeros sin embargo los
sudaneses permanecen atrapados en medio
de una crisis humanitaria el Ministerio
de salud del país informó que ya son 512
los fallecidos a causa de los combates
Samuel Salgado nos amplia
formar y aire avanzan las evacuaciones
de extranjeros en Sudán este avión de la
real fuerza aérea aterriza en el
Aeropuerto Internacional de larnaca en
chipre a bordo los primeros británicos
evacuados más de 300 pero otros 4.000 de
doble nacionalidad aún permanecen en
territorio sudanés mientras que en el
puerto de jeda en Arabia Saudita este
barco del ejército francés transportó a
personal de la ONU en total Solo este
miércoles más de 1600 personas de unas
50 nacionalidades han llegado para ser
trasladadas por mar mientras que 195
franceses evacuados ya llegaron a París
en un vuelo del ejército galo un
decidido hemos decidido enviar Esta
fragata que está en terreno y que
también nos permitirá traer de vuelta a
Europa a Francia a un cierto número de
compatriotas otros países como Marruecos
también comenzaron a evacuar a
centenares de Nacionales mientras que la
mayoría de los ciudadanos ya han sido
evacuados hacia países vecinos según
Beijing y Alemania anunció el fin de su
operativo el proceso de extracción se ha
acelerado durante el frágil y reciente
alto al fuego de 72 horas un cese de
hostilidades que alivia los extranjeros
pero no a los udaneses
estamos preocupados por los precios y
porque no sabemos En dónde refugiarnos
El problema es que el peligro está entre
nosotros somos los civiles los que
estamos sufriendo
los udaneses saben que el alto al fuego
no significa el fin del conflicto los
dos bandos en guerra el ejército regular
y el grupo paramilitar fuerzas de acción
rápida denuncian mutuamente en
cumplimiento de La tregua
mientras que la crisis humanitaria se
agrava el desabastecimiento de alimentos
y el empeoramiento del ya precario
sistema de salud provocan el temor de
los residentes De jartum que al unísono
piden que se detenga la violencia la OMS
advirtió que más del 60% de los centros
de atención médica no están funcionando
en la capital sudanesa
y en otras noticias la Unión Europea no
quiere quedarse atrás en la competición
económica con Estados Unidos y China y
para ello la comisión europea abandona
la doctrina de austeridad impuesta en el
pasado Bruselas intenta así evitar una
recesión tras la pandemia como sucedió
tras la crisis de 2008 desde la capital
europea Esther Herrera con todos los
detalles la comisión europea quiere
poner fin a la rigidez de las reglas
Fiscales que se habían aplicado hasta la
pandemia porque consideran que están
alejadas de la realidad actual aseguran
desde la comisión europea Bruselas ha
propuesto unas medidas mucho más
realistas En qué se deberá reducir la
deuda pública de los países disparada
desde la pandemia pero para poder
reducir esta deuda pública se hará de
forma mucho más gradual mucho más
paulatina y realista lo que ayudará a
países muy endeudados como Italia España
o Francia a que tendrán sanear sus
cuentas públicas pero a un ritmo mucho
más realista que no implique
automáticamente una austeridad ni unos
recortes masivos que les llevaría a una
posible recepción en todo caso las
normas principales sí que se mantendrán
es decir no podrá haber más de un 3% del
déficit ni tampoco más de un 60% de
deuda público pero para llegar a estas
cifras no se aplicará unos recortes
masivos cada año como si se habían
aplicado en el pasado cada país tendrá
que presentar unos planes nacionales a
los que la comisión europea tendrá que
dar su visto bueno si hay desvíos los
países se podrán enfrentar a multas algo
que también se contempla ahora pero
hasta ahora las multas eran excesivas y
nunca se habían llegado a aplicar
Bruselas ha caído en la evidencia que si
hay recortes no inversión y sin
inversión por lo tanto la economía
europea no puede ser competitiva ante
gigantes como Estados Unidos o china
ahora los países tendrán que dar su
vista bueno esta nueva propuesta aunque
las discusiones se prevén muy
complicadas especialmente porque
Alemania y ha dicho que esta propuesta
no le gusta que quiere más mano dura y
evitar que los países se acomoden en
exceso
y cerramos en España porque este mes de
abril amenaza con ser el más caluroso
desde que se tienen registros con
temperaturas que podrían alcanzar los 40
grados Celsius cuando faltan todavía dos
meses para el inicio del verano la
principal causa es el aire cálido y seco
proveniente de África
hasta aquí las noticias Muchísimas
gracias por su atención
[Música]